une bataille qui se poursuit sur
plusieurs fronts d'abord le front
boursier pour le contrôle d'air inter et
oui par rachats successifs ses luttes et
à qui avait pris 20% du capital d'air
inter et air france a réagi en portant
sa participation à 36% en rachetant les
parts vendues par la sncf et puis
surtout autre bataille sur le plan du
trafic air france est muté à continuent
à se disputer farouchement les lignes
dernier épisode en date on a donné
raison à air france sur la ligne de new
york mais pas sur tahiti bref la guerre
franco-française continue jacques
friedmann est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une bonne chose dans l'espace
aérien français qui vont aussi farouche
concurrence entre deux france oui je
crois d'abord que c'est pas l'élément
essentiel de la journée si vous le
permettez je crois que ce que nous avons
voulu aujourd'hui c'est surtout
présenter les résultats de air france en
1987 où l'avait indiqué qu'ils sont bons
puisque nous allons afficher 700
millions à peu près le résultat est avec
une forte progression du trafic passager
et du trafic fret marchandises
ainsi vous l'avez indiqué ce qui est
important aussi c'est de mentionner que
ces résultats qui sont bons sont
néanmoins les résultats nécessaires
parce que nous avons un fort programme
d'investissements réalisés puis parce
que les années qui vont venir seront des
années très difficile avec une
concurrence internationale
extraordinairement durs plus dure encore
que celle que nous avons connue en 87 or
voilà concurrence internationale très
dur et ça commence en france est quand
même un peu à l'intérieur de cette de
cette concurrence y est en effet la
concurrence européenne à concurrence
franco français j'aurais pas néanmoins
que l'on exagère ciblé l'importance de
ce problème le problème en effet
essentiellement problème actuellement
sur la liaison entre las la france et
les états unis nos l'autre compagnie
vite et allemande des droits sur newark
itan aéroports de new york le
gouvernement n'a pas pris de décision a
simplement demandé que nous parlions
ensemble pour essayer de trouver un
terrain d'entente nous avons parlé
ensemble maintenant c'est au
gouvernement des cités vous considérez
lutea comme un ennemi camp dans lequel
il faut se battre ou alors vous
préféreriez en faire un partenaire est
presque se sortir du temps en temps aux
solutions ce que je pense qu'il ne faut
pas se tromper de guerre je pense que
maintenant rentré depuis 1er janvier
dans l'europe transport aérien est sans
doute le premier secteur économique a
véritablement connaître l'europe le
grand marché vous allez commencer dès
maintenant à préparer même à vous mettre
d'accord avec vos partenaires européens
pour le fameux la fameuse échéance 92
ans maintenant nous y sommes ça a
commencé depuis la première étape
commencé le 1er janvier nous y sommes
alors lequel seront nos grands
concurrents nos grands concurrents ce
seront les compagnies d'extrême orient
ce sont les méga compagnie est très
grandes compagnies américaines
et par conséquent également les
compagnies européennes et moi je pense
que le transport aérien français
auraient plutôt intérêt à ce corps
donnés à
essayer d'additionner s'efforce plutôt
qu'à ce combat très sérieux client c'est
ma position ce que vous dites c'est un
peu un appel à votre collègue monsieur
l'apôtre des médias pour parler ensemble
et sans nous avons beaucoup parlé nous
nous voyons est ce que je souhaite c'est
que nous arrivions à une coopération
pour affronter ensemble cette
concurrence internationale qui sera très
dur si le gouvernement pour une autre
décision est bien à ce moment là vous
savez air france n'a pas peur la
concurrence nous sommes dans concurrents
sur toutes les lignes dans l'italie
monopole s'est terminée
une toute dernière question dans l'état
actuel de la concurrence internationale
qui est farouche surtout avec les
américains est ce que vous pensez qu'il
y aura des morts qu'il ya déjà des
compagnies qui sont en train de
pratiquement d agoniser aux états unis
ce que vous pensez que cela continue a
su persuader su persuader que dans les
quelques années qui viennent notamment
en europe seules quelques grandes
compagnies subsiste heures
tout le problème pour air france ces
dettes parmi ces grandes compagnies je
pense que nous allons être certain d'en
avoir les moyens je pense que les
résultats de 87 nous permettent de
penser que nous en avons les moyens que
nous sommes bien placés pour réussir il
faut simplement poursuivre les efforts
ça n'est pas donné c'est notamment
l'objet du projet entrepris de
l'intérieur d'air france que nous avons
mises en oeuvre c'est le projet tous les
efforts que nous continuerons à faire
nous avons cinq ans pour réussir puisque
le 1er janvier 93 ça sera cette fois le
vrai marché
aérien européen unique et je pense que
nous partons avec de bons atouts nous
avons également les faiblesses nous
avons un qui résume toute notre action
et notre philosophie c'est la
compétitivité il faut que soyons
compétitifs compétitif sur le plan des
prix compétitifs sur la qualité du
service compétitifs sur le plan de notre
politique commerciale et bien ce sera le
mot de la fin merci jay freeman couteau